kameena this week bob geldof took to
social media to galvanize the nation
into taking part in the people's vote
march because he says quotes
Parliament's afraid of democracy so the
people must bring democracy to
Parliament stop it June sorry but the
people who are afraid of democracy are
the political elitist and
multi-millionaire celebrities who never
tire of telling us for stupid racist
levers how we should live they're the
ones trying to overturn the biggest
Democratic vote this country has ever
had sorry but power against celebrities
need to get their heads around the fact
that people know their own minds and
won't be dissuaded from their beliefs by
anything they say their personal
opinions their politics mean nothing to
us they are significant only in their
own tiny minds we pay our hard-earned
cash to hear them sing to dance to play
pretend people on stage and screen but
they need to understand their only job
is to entertain us not to lecture pack
your knives and belittle in the very
people who made them famous as one sage
said on Twitter this week you are merely
marionettes to us so sing dance but on
everything else shut up
[Music]
well that TVs about that TV show ain't
our ain't half hot mum slated us all as
racist anyway so I'm gonna quote the
wonderful Bill Maher here so when the
u.s. election was happening and it
looked like Trump was going up in the
polls and perhaps he had a shot of
winning mm-hmm he did a monologue to the
young people of America and he said
young people you know in your films when
the lead says you're gonna have to bleep
me out here this just got real mm-hmm
that just got real and I think with
everything that's happened and I'm using
America as an example I think with
everything that's happened with
Cavanaugh and and just the blatant
disrespect for women we've seen in
America that is why I'm going to use
Taylor Swift's example that is why
somebody like Taylor Swift is standing
up and standing out so I think the
question we should be asking is why is
it that an a political star like a
Taylor Swift feels that she needs to
respond in this way it doesn't I'm not
interested in what she thinks I don't
care what tell us what can I tell you
what Taylor Swift writing how'd you say
yeah so yeah but I want to talk about
Taylor Swift because I think this is
what really got this in the press even
more so than Bob Geldof so going into
the next debate this is great anyway so
this is what she had to say I'm writing
this post about the upcoming midterm
elections on November 6 in which I'll be
voting in the state of Tennessee in the
past I've been reluctant to publicly
voice my political opinions but I feel
very differently about that now I cannot
support Marsha Blackburn her voting
record in Congress our pulls and
terrifies me I will be voting for Phil
Breslin for Senate and Jim Cooper for
the House of Representatives
now once she issued wait once she issued
that Instagram post vote.org saw an
increase of 65,000 voter registrations
and a spike in Tennessee
so you're talking about celebrities when
there's bad almost like to happen okay
okay that's not gonna happen unit with
that I think what a lot of celebrities
miss in their arrogance is the family
call you at 11:00 no Kara no no I'm
talking about people I'm talking about
the people who voted nothing what
celebrities miss is the kind of people
who voted for the president it's not
it's not white old people that voted for
breakfast its people well there's people
like you and me and journalists okay you
think it's old people 58% of it's
between 25 and 49 endorse breaks it
breaks didn't toast by one and four
British graduates one in three black and
ethnic minorities one in two women
wasn't it more effective April over 60
live it up we are the architects of your
funeral because we have radio stations
the TV stations and use but Bob Geldof
thinks this Bono's that juicy pictures
baggage oh it's looking Bob Geldof here
this is what this is what this this to
me became the image of the chattering
classes before the brig's of them let's
see this picture that's him don't Carol
I was on the blink was not sticking it
see more efficient fisherman he was
sticking his finger up at night with a
mission so II with them you've been
talking to would we as jobbing hacks
have to write and talk about if
celebrities did not shoot their mouths
off and wade into political debate the
point also can I just one more thing I
think you'd be criticizing celebrities
if they stayed completely out to
politics you'll be saying no you have a
platform we've got very low road voter
registration why don't they come out and
tell us about
the report was and and more of cuz they
are they're not because they're nothing
you're talking like hourly who voted
tomorrow you won't have this debate if
there wasn't if their opinions weren't
important talking about singing pop song
okay we do a complete reverse just think
you're living on a fantasy planet Carol
we've got President Trump in the White
House a reason have made himself Ronald
Reagan that my brothers we live in an
era where if you want to win in politics
you embrace celebrity and it
I just thought actually that's right I
say it's reality of course I'm not happy
about someone like Trump becoming
president you know I think it's
everything was wrong with democracy but
it's happening I can't stop it and the
point is that because I had his base was
people who watch reality TV
ya know talking about Taylor Swift it's
not good for democracy when whole
demographic groups don't vote young
people automatically underrepresented in
voter registration if a celebrity who
has reached among young voters her main
point was to get people to register to
vote Democratic about trying to overturn
the biggest Democratic vote this country
is that I think you'll just use that
play senses you're using this topic just
as a way to have a go at people who want
a second referendum not so if you're
really talking about celebrities you've
got John Cleese pretending and literally
to him on social media sales leave I
haven't heard you laying in for them
there are celebrities who've used their
plaque and we do have a leave campaign
freedom of speech Carol why shouldn't
they say what's the biggest democratic
vote we have ever had you see it is
about breakfast what I don't think that
celebrities miss here is the reasons
that people voted for exit there were
people and working-class well you're
laughing at this topic this is should
celebrity not don't get what they signed
a leave side an heiress let's finish my
sentence celebrities attack people who
voted leave for I think are terrible
reason they don't poppers celebrities
understand the reasons why questions
used about to say you mind the
celebrities that came out in favorably
you should be giving them opinion why
should they be using a European judge me
why does your opinion matter to hold on
the nation that's fine well then why
should we listen to your body trying to
influence anyone to vote oh you're on
the show that clearly is no I am Eva and
I'm not unbeliever but I'm not trying to
get other people to you guys I was a
reluctant yeah I've told you how many
times I said this is not to satisfy me
is it not about whether celebrities
should have argued against brexit
publicly it's where the celebrity should
be allowed to say yes but we give them
as I said before give them too much of a
microphone whether it be on the print if
editors actually said I don't care what
John Key says I don't care what Bob
Geldof says then it would don't know
actually the people are that's true I
don't know that people wake up tomorrow
morning you know you casting celebrities
as marionettes you know that's what I
did it was an add-on that is why we've
had actresses being abused I know we're
gonna have a finish the idea that if
your celebrity have no right to have an
opinion no right to express you of you
no right to have agency in politics they
can charge your aggression you don't
have a right to judge if they do you via
heard the name some of the celebrities
called divas like headless chickens the
headless to clarify having a proper name
is Hannah
we must celebrities don't leave on this
debate